but now we need to talk about
vladimir maric putin
who was a kgb a mid-ranked kgb thug
who claims never really to have believed
in the communist claptrap that he was
putting out which is which wouldn't make
him unique among the soviet apparatchiki
um
but who nevertheless obviously imbibed a
sense of soviet patriotism
and some kind of belief in aspects of
that ideology and has certainly
accepted
the soviet theory
that the west that the world is out to
get
russia and accepted that paranoia
doctrine because i mean as you as you
know jordan
ideologies are large sprawling and
complex people can believe in parts of
them while rejecting other parts of them
i'm willing to believe that putin was
never a committed communist per se
but it is apparent that putin accepted
the special destiny of the soviet union
or russia
in the world to be a superpower and to
have influence beyond the norm
and accepted that the world was hostile
and was seeking to prevent
the soviet union or russia from having
that role
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased to have with
me today dr frederick w kagan
i reached out to some of my contacts who
have some intellectual
credibility and some political expertise
to find out
who
could be contacted to provide an update
for everyone me included on
the unfolding situation in russia and
ukraine and
dr frederick kagan his name popped up
instantly so i'll give you a bit of a
bio and then we'll get right to the
issue what's happening in the ukraine
dr frederick w kagan
is author of the 2007 report
choosing victory a plan for success in
iraq he's one of the intellectual
architects of the surge strategy in iraq
he's the director of the american
enterprise institute's critical threats
project and a former professor of
military history at the u u.s military
academy at west point his books range
from lessons for a long war
american enterprise institute press 2010
co-authored with thomas donnelly to the
end of the old order napoleon and europe
1805 1801 to 1805 decapo press 2006 he
worked as an assistant professor of
military history at west point from 95
to 2001
and as an associate professor of
military history from 2001 to 2005.
dr kagan holds a phd
in russian and soviet military history
from yale so
welcome thanks for agreeing to talk to
me today i very much appreciate it i'm
looking forward to this insofar as you
can look forward to a discussion about
such topics and so
we'll get right to the heart of the
matter i guess uh in the most pointed
manner possible maybe you could give us
some sense of of what's happening right
now and then we'll move to why and what
we should do about it and but as far as
you're concerned how should we be
understanding the events that are
unfolding in ukraine
so um
several days ago i've confessed i've
lost all track of of time
but several days ago uh vladimir russian
president vladimir putin launched
an unprovoked and unjustified and
illegal
attack on ukraine
for the purpose of conquering it
he has conducted air and missile strikes
against multiple multiple targets across
the entire country
and he has launched a ground invasion
along multiple axes
his objective is very clearly to
take control of the ukrainian government
in kiev
but also take control of a lot of other
territory in ukraine
he obviously aims at a minimum to
replace
the pro-western
government headed by volody mirzalensky
ukraine's current president
and install some kind of governance
structure uh that will bring ukraine um
as he sees it back into the russian fold
uh it's not at all obvious to me or
anyone really what uh kind of governance
structure putin has in mind at this
point
um but it is very clear that he intends
to do this at the point that the at the
muzzle of the tank
and that he is willing to kill quite a
lot of people
and do quite a lot of damage in ukraine
uh in order to
regain control of the country and that
is that is
that is what is going on
in short it's part of a larger effort
that putin is engaged in to reconstitute
the the soviet union in some way
or possibly the tsarist empire in some
way
the the geographies of the soviet union
and the tsarist empire had
interesting overlaps and under laps and
it's important to keep in mind that
putin refers to both when he's talking
about what his uh
what his aims are um
and then just you know the last larger
thing to zoom out from all of that
uh he's been very explicit about his
intention to destroy the nato alliance
uh to break the ties between the united
states and europe
uh to change the world order
fundamentally
and to return the united states to what
he regards as its proper sphere which is
a western hemispheric power
so let me let me ask you some questions
about about the way you answered that so
you started out by saying unprovoked
unwarranted
and illegal and then you switched to so
i'd like to delve into that why all of
those and then
one one might
conclude that there's territorial
ambitions here in some sense but and he
is moving troops into a large
geographical area
uh of some value merely because it's a
geographical area but you also
highlighted the importance of uh
of a uh a shift in governance in ukraine
away from a pro
western
governance structure and so
how how much of this should we assume is
territorial in some sense and how much
of it is his his desire
to create a subordinate state is it to
support a state subordinate to him or is
it more important to him do you think
that it's not pro-western
his objective is very explicitly to
change the political order in ukraine
it's not about territorial conquest per
se
it's about
ending ukraine's ambitions to join
to be part of the west to begin with
but he has written
lengthy articles
and he has given lengthy speeches
um explaining that he
thinks that ukraine has no right to
exist as an independent state uh that it
has no nationhood
uh that it is simply a natural part of
russia that was left from russia
uh by the stupid soviets and then by
what you know the what he has called the
greatest geopolitical disaster of the
20th century which was the fall of the
soviet union
so it's it's it's apparent from
everything that he says that his
ultimate objective is to regain
uh full control over ukraine in some way
um the exact way in which he would
govern a re-conquered ukraine
is not yet clear but that he would in
that he is insisting that it be
in russia's sphere of influence under
russia's control is not it's not in
question
so let let's talk let's ask about this
idea the russian sphere of influence
because
one of the things that puzzles me in
some sense is
why isn't russia why doesn't russia
conceptualize itself
as part of the west like why is russia
why does russia insist upon
viewing itself as an entity independent
of the west especially given the fact
that it isn't exactly obvious that putin
is an admirer of what happened under
lenin and stalin in the soviet union and
so i don't understand why he why we have
to have this notion that it's russia
against the west is why he doesn't trust
the west we don't trust him like what's
the dynamic i know they're trying to
find a fourth way or something like that
philosophically in russia
why are we in this situation where
russia doesn't conceptualize itself as
part of the west
i love this question this is this is
great because if you let me get in do
some of my nerdly historian stuff here
to begin with russia has has never
considered itself fully part of the west
um
you know when peter the great broke a
window into europe in the in the magical
phrase of of uh pushkin
um
by establishing saint petersburg peter
attempted who is one of putin's two
great heroes in russian and soviet
history the other one being stalin
um
peter
was trying to westernize russia and ever
since then
there has been a debate within russia
about whether russia really is western
or part of the west or whether it is
something else in the 19th century this
manifested itself particularly in the
distinction in the divide in russian
intelligentsia between uh westerners and
slavophiles and you had people like leo
tolstoy um arguing for the inherent uh
you know russian soul
as being distinctive and unique
um
from the end of the napoleonic wars on
russia politically has regarded itself
as something more than european
and the acquisition of russian is asian
territories among other things in the
19th century
uh has led russians to see themselves as
european and also throughout the 19th
century obviously the west was europe
you know the united states was not a big
player in being the west
in the 20th century it's hard to know
exactly where russia would have gone
except that bolshevism
which triumphed in 1917
was an explicit rejection of the western
political economic model
and a move in a different unique
direction so there is a narrative of
russian uniqueness
and there is an inherent sort of russian
messianism and the messianism actually
goes all the way back to eve on the
terrible and i'm happy to talk about
that if you'd love to delve into into
ancient history but
there are these strands in russian
thought going back centuries
that russia is a unique kind of place
and that it must be a unique kind of
place and then of course as the soviet
union was one of two global superpowers
with the united states
putin when putin's talking about the
geostrategic calamity of the fall of the
soviet union what he really means is the
loss of
russia's privileged position
as one of the two rulers of the world
and what he is aspiring to is
re-establishing that oh i've tried to
understand this this russian
exceptionalism i mean i'm an admirer of
russian literature and
solzhenitsyn certainly did
um
feel that it would be
appropriate for russia if it could throw
off the shackles of its soviet
totalitarianism to return to the
russian orthodox tradition that
undergirded the tsarist regimes let's
say and he felt that that would a return
to that would produce the foundation
that would allow proper movement forward
but that still to me doesn't exactly
seem to justify claims that in some
sense this is a non-western enterprise i
mean insofar as it's grounded in
orthodox christianity it's still
grounded in christianity which makes it
broadly western and
i've tried to understand but but but but
no but not okay not not not on the
russian historical conceptions because
the
the the messianism of that is was
established under um
the yvonne the yvonne rulers was the
notion of moscow as the third rome
and the argument was that there first
there was rome and christianity was
founded there christianity moved to
constantinople
and then when constantinople fell in
1453
the russian orthodox church began to
make the argument that the center of
christendom had moved to moscow which
was the inheritor of the true faith
so in that sense it is a line of
christianity that does not that rejects
sort of rome as the center anymore runs
through constantinople to moscow and
claims to be its own center and so even
in that sense christ's defining
christianity as a western thing in this
sense is problematic within the
ideological framework
that putin and others operate well so
they see that as more embedded in the
busi in in the remnants of the byzantine
empire and yeah and in the separation
from constantinople and rome a very long
time ago correct and do you know
anything about the relationship between
the orthodox christian
authority hierarchy in russia and the
hierarchies of authority in rome are the
relationships good or do the orthodox
does the orthodox hierarchy itself
regard itself as something separate
entirely and in opposition to the oh it
is it is separate the the the orthodox
hierarchy in in russia does not um
regard itself as under the under the
edict no but are the are the
relationships friendly and and is there
communication or miscommunication and
successor popes have reached out to
uh patriarchs to to talk
uh with them but one of the things that
it's important to understand is that
putin has carried on the tradition of
the tsars
um
of
subordinating the moscow patriarchate to
himself
and so the the it is that the moscow
patriarchate at this point is
fundamentally an arm of the russian
government
and so he controls it de facto
uh it is not an independent
of religious authority in reality even
though it is ostensibly and so
its relations with the vatican are
whatever putin decides he's willing to
have them be
at any given moment i don't think i
don't understand there to be a
particularly contentious relationship
except
um and it wasn't with the vatican
actually most recently if you want to
get really nerdy on this there was a big
fight a couple of years ago
because the ukrainian orthodox church
had been
a component or subordinated to the
moscow patriarchate
um
the formal uh leader of all of the
orthodox uh communities is in um
constantin is in kai i want
and a few years ago i forgot exactly
when
the ukrainian orthodox church petitioned
the uh patriarch in istanbul to grant it
autocephaly to make it independent of
the moscow patriarchate and that was
granted
and so the ukrainian orthodox church has
become an independent
uh entity directly under the
constantinople of the istanbul uh
patriarch
and the putin bitterly resented that
hated it
attacked it uh and it was it is one of
his grievances that in fact that that
occurred that was not done by the pope
that was done by the uh patriarchy
people might be wondering why we've
taken a detour into a religious
direction but the answer is we're trying
to sort out the issue of the degree to
which russia rightly regards itself as
an autonomous community independent of
the west and in order to answer that
question properly you have to delve down
to the bottom of the cultural separation
and near the bottom is well the relative
autonomy of the orthodox church i have
talked to people in washington who are
associated with the orthodox church in
russia and they do claim that putin goes
to confession and that there is some
validity to his claims to have adopted
some approximation of orthodox
christianity that obviously leaves open
the issue of what the relationship is
between the political power and the
church power it doesn't seem to be
entirely unidirectional and one of the
things that also is a mystery to me in
relationship to that is that you can
trace a fairly clear line of development
of democratic thought in the west proper
to protestantism in particular which is
grounded in christianity and there's a
fair bit of emphasis on individual
sovereignty and orthodox christianity
but there wasn't a development into a
into a democratic polity in the same way
there was especially in northern europe
and i can't i i can't really understand
why that is it doesn't seem to be a
doctrinal issue exactly that stems from
the the faith itself it but i i don't
have any more
i'm i am i'm going i'm about to reach
the limit of of expertise that i'm
comfortable talking about but i will i
will make the observation that
one of the central characteristics of
protestantism is that apart from um
england
after henry viii protestantism was
independent of state control right right
and even catholicism
was independent of state control for
most of the history of the west after
the fall of rome
and so
um that i think
it's very that independence from state
control has been an important element in
allowing in the fact that western
religion that christianity in the west
it's created space as it were by right
by creating
this separation this gap between church
and state
in which at the level of detail at the
level of legislation and and actual
interactions between the church and the
state yeah and just the comp i mean this
is what you know of course why henry one
of the reasons henry viii took control
of the
you know went to the protestant
anglicanism and took control of his own
church because he was aggravated to
having a pope
um you know being have have a say in
anything
but in most other countries in europe
the pope continued to have a say in
things for a long time and it created a
little bit of space that was never the
case in russia we never had
an independent patriarch
who could create that space from the
tsars
um
into which there's you know something
else could happen because it was always
fundamentally um
at least in the from the muscovite
period on it was uh the orthodox church
was always fundamentally under the
control of the tsar
and so it was a state religion and it
was not it just did not have the ability
to create that kind of
space and then there's a bunch of other
socio-cultural reasons that you know as
a historian i'd love to nerd out about
why the russians didn't develop western
traditions of
personal liberty and independence and
that kind of stuff but this religious
aspect has to do with state capture
state control of the church i think more
than anything else right so too much
integration at the top which is that's
how mussolini defined fascism in some
sense although he was thinking more
about it in terms of collusion between
the corporate world and the
and the political world but
so you need autonomous organizations
as close to the top as you can get at
at least that's worked that's how it's
worked in the west okay so we've talked
about why russia might regard itself as
somehow importantly separate i mean you
could also say that about
any number of countries within the west
it's not like germany and england are
the same place or france and england or
france in the united states we've been
able to develop
an integrated west to some degree that
also allows for autonomy so i still
can't exactly see why the russians can't
be brought under that umbrella
certainly the idea that they've lost
their empire and they've lost their
central place
that there's a i don't know if there's a
resentment that goes along with that or
well confusion about place yeah before
you even get there i mean look it you
can't understand
the
importance of the bolshevik revolution
in this regard because
the romanov dynasty especially in the
19th century regarded itself as a part
of europe as well as something more it
regarded itself as european plus
um and it regarded itself as a sort of a
european superpower but it regarded
itself as part of the concert of europe
and a pillar of the concert of europe
so
the change comes when you have a
revolutionary cabal take power
that is dedicated to the destruction of
all of the fundamental principles of the
west
and that was the but that was the
bolshevik revolution
and it took it took control and it
imposed its ideology by brute
unbelievably brutal force on a
population that didn't
start believing in it
and that ideology involved
not only that the every aspect of the
socio-political economic structure of
the west was evil
but that it was seeking to destroy
russia and that it was seeking to
destroy this virtuous bolshevik
revolution
so we can talk about the you know the
historical russian theories of
encirclement and various other things um
which frankly can be easily overstated
when you go back into russian history
but the bolsheviks absolutely saw
themselves as the the kernel of a world
revolution
and assumed naturally that the entire
capitalist world
was seeking to destroy them
and
to be fair to them
of course the initial reaction
of the western powers was in fact to try
to crush the bolshevik revolution and we
did have american troops land in russia
in
during the civil war to try to help the
white forces defeat the bolsheviks so
there was an initial
western end the british and the french
did too so there was an initial sort of
western intervention against the
bolshevik revolution which gave just a
little bit of color to this but the
anti-westernism and the notion of an
encirclement and being a permanent war
with the entire capitalist world
is inherent to
marxism and leninism
and then what did the bolsheviks do they
systematically cut
the soviet society off from the world
and took all control of communications
prevented people from leaving the soviet
union it's one of the ways that you can
tell
a legitimate state from a prison with a
government
is does it allow its people freely to
leave
and the soviet union did not
the soviet union proved you know the
laws prevented people from leaving
without special permissions and so on
and so it was a prison within the
certain the certain hallmark of a
totalitarian society is that you cannot
it's a prison essentially exactly right
so
that was so the russians so that you
think there's inertia in some sense even
though russia is no longer a bolshevik
state you think there's inertia in the
distrust of the west that probably
developed even before the bolshevik
revolution
not i i don't think that there was a
huge amount of inertia along those lines
among russians themselves
but now we need to talk about
vladimir maric putin
who was a kgb a mid-ranked kgb thug
who claims never really to have believed
in the communist claptrap that he was
putting out which is which wouldn't make
him unique among the soviet apology
but who nevertheless obviously imbibed a
sense of soviet patriotism
and some kind of belief in aspects of
that ideology and has certainly
accepted
the soviet theory
that the west that the world is out to
get russia
and accepted that paranoia doctrine
because i mean as you as you know jordan
ideologies are large sprawling and
complex people can believe in parts of
them while rejecting other parts of them
i'm willing to believe that putin was
never a committed communist per se
but it is apparent that putin accepted
the special destiny of the soviet union
or russia
in the world to be a superpower and to
have influence beyond the norm
and accepted that the world was hostile
and was seeking to prevent
the soviet union or russia from having
that role okay so then is it is it the
case then that and this is part of the
expression of political
uh what variability and opinion that you
hear expressed in the united states
right now it's it was definitely the
case and correct me if i'm wrong my
understanding is that after the soviet
wall fell
that the west did take steps quite
rapidly to try to consolidate some of
the border territories between
the former soviet union in the west and
to invite the baltic states and so forth
into a much closer partnership with the
west and a lot of that happened quite
quickly and then
ukraine was sort of left in an
in-between state for a long time
so it didn't get moved west as fast as
some of the other states did yeah can i
i mean i'd like to clean up the history
here because i think that okay i think
good
details matter so
the soviet union formally ends at the
end of 1991.
um
there is there is discussion about
exactly what's going to happen to
germany and about whether east germany
is going to become a part of nato and
the russians have a certain
idea of what we of what they were told
and we have a different idea of what
they were told there were no formal
commitments one way or another but it
ended with germany being reunited
and then all of germany remaining in
nato
um there was no further expansion of
nato until 1997
okay so that's very important it is not
like in in 1990 not like the year after
the soviet union fell nato expanded
nor is it the case that the messages
were that were going from the west to
russia were
we're going to take all of the
non-russia parts of the former soviet
union into nato but you russians need to
stay out you're the adversary on the
contrary nato reached out to russia also
and nato established a partnership for
peace program and russia was a member of
the partnership for peace program along
with all of the other former soviet
states
and nato did offer various forms of
technical assistance the us formed
various for offered various forms of
technical assistance
uh to russia in the 1990s uh most of
which the russians um rejected some of
which they accepted which were which
were very important there was a lot of
cooperation because it's important to
note that when boris yeltsin was
president he did not identify the west
as the enemy
he sought to integrate into the west he
sought to westernize russia and he'd and
he did to a considerable extent and he
sought to democratize russia and he did
and he had to fight off multiple efforts
by the communist party of this former
soviet union
to regain power
and re-establish communist rule
and he fought against that and we tried
we did try to help him with that
but the first nato expansion doesn't
happen until 1997 and it did not include
the baltic states the the baltic states
were admitted in i think 2003 2004 i
forgotten except the exact date um in
there but they were they were not
admitted in that first tranche
so the notion that we somehow just
immediately started snapping up
uh you know former warsaw pact states
and then baltic states into the alliance
is false
nor is it the case that that was
initially done in a way
in our in in the way that we expressed
it to the russians as being aimed at
threatening russia
these states sought admission into the
alliance and look we've got to
recognize that the alliance was formed
on a principle of
an open door policy that always that is
inherent that is innate in the north
atlantic charter that founded the
alliance that any state can request
admission to the alliance this is one of
the things that putin is demanding that
nato change
but that provision was not added or
created after the end of the cold war it
was created when the alliance was
created
now obviously the alliance doesn't have
to choose to admit any particular
member
but we can now ask another question
which is why
what did we the west think that nato was
doing in the 90s and why were we
admitting these former warsaw pact and
then the baltic states to the alliance
yes we were we wanted to make sure that
we had a buffer against the kind of
threat the soviets had brought
into central europe because it's
important to keep in mind that the cold
war was shaped by the fact
that whereas we the united states and
britain and then restored france as we
uh liberated territories we made them
free
and we they we offered them the
opportunity to join nato they did join
nato and which became a very
rambunctious alliance which periodically
told the united states to pound sand and
which we did not run as an empire soviet
uh rhetoric notwithstanding
and it was an alliance of free states
and it was a it is a purely defensive
alliance there is absolutely no
offensive provision in the nato charter
anywhere so that's what we did what did
the soviets do well with the red army
rolled into eastern europe
it did not liberate anybody
it drove off the german forces and then
it took control of those countries
installed puppet states which were ruled
from moscow how do we know that because
there were periodic revolutions
in the eastern european states which the
united states and nato did not foment
and did not support
and which the soviets crushed brutally
with tanks repeatedly
so they established an empire in eastern
europe and they brought
millions of forces into the heart of
europe and threatened to overrun all of
western europe and that was the threat
against which nato was formed
i tell you all of that to say that
people talk about the buffer that the
russians feel that they need against the
west
the nato expansion was about giving the
west a buffer from the threat that it
had just managed to drive off
of vast soviet mechanized armies in the
heart of europe poised to overrun all of
the west
so that there was absolutely a security
thing nato is a security alliance and
the big part of this was gaining a
buffer for the west
so that europe could actually have peace
and develop peacefully and without fear
which the threat of soviet invasion
throughout the cold war had denied it
but in addition to that
the nato accession was also meant to
help
bring those uh warsaw pact states and
then the baltic states into compliance
with nato standards
which is not just about military stuff
it's also about legal
moral ethical frameworks
that about how we fight wars about how
we treat our soldiers about how the
military interacts with the civilian
population
it was meant to be part of an effort
that was successful
to help those countries develop healthy
democracies and healthy free market
economies and we invest
and the capacity for some autonomous
function at the national level or for
for full autonomous function at the
national level right complete complete
so we don't control them right
so you're laying out an argument
essentially that claims that um
to to view
this as a
dual
a duopoly let's say it's the us and its
satellites against russian it's
satellites that's a profound
misapprehension of the historical
reality because it wasn't russia and its
satellites it was the soviet union which
was a block and it's america with its
allies so america sits as first among
equals let's say something like that in
a voluntary organization that's
predicated on the preservation of
freedom at the political level and at
the economic level and if we want
evidence for that we look at the
the response of well the wall in in
berlin for example to take not the least
of the examples but the crushing of
hungary and czechoslovakia and and
almost poland when the soviet union did
fall and look at the response to any
manifestation of genuine autonomy on the
part of the soviets so okay well we
still have a question that's that's
lurking constantly in the background
it's like
why in the world would the russia the
russians are prone to
rejected invitation to become part of
the sovereign voluntary association of
western states for some reason they
distrust the west we've talked about
that they regard themselves as having an
autonomous destiny but
but
hypothetically that could have still
happened so
let's take a slightly different tack
what did let's let's imagine we're
trying to figure out what did we do
wrong in negotiating with the russians
in the last 20 years and what did the
russians do wrong in conceptualizing
themselves and then negotiating with us
so let's start with us maybe like we're
in this situation well hang on hang on
before i mean before we do that there's
a okay there's a sea change that happens
in russia
um when putin takes power
because yeltsin had been one thing
and then putin is something else
entirely
and
putin was had become an anti-communist
in the 1990s and he helped yeltsin
fight off the attempts of the communists
to regain power
and initially i think by the way putin
identified himself as a democrat and a
and someone who was in favor of
democracy
um which worked for him as long as he
was actually winning elections you know
handily and and didn't have to rig them
and he didn't have to rig the first few
elections
um very much and he could allow them to
be relatively free because he was
popular
um
so but it's it's putin who brought a new
approach to this
and it's putin who brought a real sense
of grievance and anger
and the grievance was about the fall
from greatness of the soviet union now
the one thing that it is necessary to
to have in people's minds here
the 1990s
was a horrific time for russians
okay i want to set aside the question of
our responsibility or what we did or
couldn't have done because the truth the
truth is i will i will assert and i
would be happy to argue with anybody
about that
if this wasn't our fault and there
wasn't much we could have done about it
frankly anyway
are you talking about the 90s
specifically about what's yeah yes well
yeah the 90s were a catastroph by my
son-in-law former son-in-law was russian
and
he said often when he went to school he
him and his
close relatives who are also attending
school weren't necessarily sure they
were going to come home alive through
much of the early 90s it was crazy i was
there in 1995 uh doing doing research in
the russian archives and the ruble
dropped from 3 000 to the dollar to five
thousand to the dollar in the five weeks
that i was there doing research uh one
time
it was it was absolute i was i went to
the first i went to the first mcdonald's
on on uh todaskaya uh square
uh as it as it opened and it was it was
an amazing it was an amazing thing so i
i saw a little bit i mean i was standing
around there were guards with ak-47s
guarding vegetable markets as i would
walk by them you know why was that going
on because everybody was getting cuts
and their rival gangs were controlling
every aspect of it it was completely
insane it was an unbelievable it was a
horrible period for russians to live
through
and it was an unbelievable humiliation
for someone like putin who believes in
russia that russia should be one of the
world's two superpowers to have gone
through that experience
so yeltsin tried to lead his country
through that with its democracy intact
and he succeeded until putin destroyed
it he be elton was never able to to fix
the economy really
um so putin comes in with a deep sense
of grievance and burning in with
humiliation at what had happened to the
russians in the 90s and he needed an
explanation
that came readily to hand for why that
had happened and on the one hand he
blamed garbachoth
for
surrendering
instead of fighting and he bitterly
resents the fact that kobuchov didn't
kill as many millions of people as he
needed to just to stay in power
but he also blamed the west uh in many
respects
quite some mostly unfairly honestly
uh for russia's humiliation
and then we had
a narrative rapidly emerge in the early
putin years
that not only had the west contributed
to russia's humiliation in this way and
mistreated russia in various ways in the
90s but now the west was trying to
prevent russia as he kept saying from
rising from its knees
and that the west was trying to keep
russia down
and as he began to elaborate a series of
narratives
which attributed all kinds of
malevolence and frankly much more
uh thinking and and coherence in western
policies than has ever existed
to us and also made the mistake that
most humans make of solipsism of
imagining that he was at the center of
everybody's thought
and that everything that we were doing
in the world was aimed at russia in some
way
and so he created this narrative which
he has been pumping into the russian
population ever since well when things
are going chaotically wrong
one of the simplest things to do always
is to identify
the
make a unitary assumption of cause and
to make it external of course it's
convenient in 50 ways right first of all
it gives you an enemy to unite against
it gives you an enemy to talk about
politically
um it solves your conscience it's also
very simple because the reason that the
uk that this former soviet union was so
catastrophically chaotic in the 1990s
the reasons for that are unbelievably
complicated and detailed and they go all
the way from the highest levels of
government to the nature of arrangements
within families right the whole society
was authoritarian for what 70 years
murderously authoritarian and to unravel
that and to take responsibility for it
and to figure out how to fix it is way
harder than to blame almost all of it on
an external enemy right especially when
you're also motivated as you said by
this sense of thwarted destiny which we
could identify i mean in the west we do
regard a certain degree of patriotism as
noble and
and justifiable and you can see how that
under some conditions noble and
justifiable motivation would get
hijacked if there was also
reason to externalize blame for
conditions for resentment generated by
genuine chaos right
right i mean look okay just i mean in
addition to all the other factors you
listed we need to keep in mind how
how enormous was the task of trying to
convert the russian econ the soviet
economy to a free market
basically you know industrialization in
russia fundamentally happened under the
soviets
and it was done to a planned centralized
economy
so russia is still littered today with
what are called monotones they're towns
of half a million people
that exist around a single huge factory
in which 75 or 100 000 people work
that was the soviet model
the task of taking an economy built like
that and turning it into a free market
economy would have been
unbelievably
daunting with the best of the will in
the world
and unfortunately yeltsin
was preoccupied with the fight against
the communists and keeping russia
democratic
i don't know whether he ever would have
been able to undertake that mission
successfully anyway of marketizing the
russian economy but he wasn't even able
to concentrate on it
well that and as you point out that
that's not merely a conceptual issue no
part of the reason that free market
frameworks work in the west is because
the actual industries and micro
industries and small shops are all
autonomous and distributed and so the
legal structure matches the actual
infrastructure whereas in the soviet
union as you said because it was
centralized there's these massive
entities that are not
uh not distributed or autonomous in any
sense at all and just changing the legal
framework doesn't change that in the
least exactly exactly so it was it was a
huge task and all of this leads to the
externalization
of grievance
and the narrow and the feeding of a
grievance narrative that blames the west
and then and then articulates this
theory that the west is focused on
preventing russia from attaining for its
natural position of greatness in the
world and so on
and then putin who is was a spymaster he
wasn't a terribly good one with the kgb
but he was a spymaster
begins
and launches on a new form of
uh conflict
which we now call hybrid war
um
sorry the phrase is hybrid hybrid hybrid
war yeah yeah yeah um a phrase that's
very complicated to talk about and
understand but that includes information
operations and information warfare
that can best be characterized by by the
term gaslighting
and this is the stock and trade of the
russian hybrid warfare effort
there's a soviet concept and there was a
terrific paper at the institute for the
study of war uh that my wife kim founded
and runs and that i where i i
work with the russia team there but
there was a terrific paper that they
published a few years ago by a woman
named maria sneagawaya on russian
reflexive control a soviet reflexive
control doctrine uh because the soviet
it was soviet theorists who articulated
this framework um in the 50s or 60s i
don't remember that putin and his goons
have taken and perfected
reflexive control is the art of
creating a
world a picture of the world in your
adversary's mind
of such a fashion that your adversary
voluntarily chooses the course of action
that you desire him to choose thinking
that it is in his in his best interest
that's a very complicated way of saying
gaslighting right you create a false
universe for the adversary to live in
and in that universe the adversary will
naturally do what you want him to do
this is what the russians have been
trying to do okay and what okay so i
have two questions about that the first
is as soon as anything like that is put
forth it instantly sounds like a
conspiracy theory and i'm not saying
that you're engaging in conspiracy
theories but that's the reflexive
response so what's the evidence for your
questions
and then and what what's the narrative
they're trying to create how effective
has that been
and while we we've already unders we
under already understand to some degree
why if the west is being conceptualized
as an an enemy responsible for russian
chaos for keeping the russians down and
for encircling them
depriving them of their just destiny
then we know the motive there's others
but that's not a bad core motive what's
the warfare aimed at and what's the
evidence that this is occurring and how
and where and how are we subject to it
all of that
so right as soon as you're operating in
the information space and as soon as
you're dealing with this kind of
psychological warfare and stuff
um
i i will tell you there's there's a
mountain of evidence that this is going
on and it's deliberate and lots of
people can argue with that um
and can certainly we can argue about the
specifics but
the evidence is first of all this is a
published soviet doctrine which we have
which we can read you can read the state
where this is articulated
and then there is russian doctrine on
warfare and on hybrid warfare
that also explicitly lays out this
framework
so
the the barrier to entry here is reading
russian if you can read russian
then you can read official russian
doctrine and documents
laying out the theory of hybrid warfare
and how to conduct it now there's one
trick in in the way that they in the way
that they tend to articulate this most
clearly and we've written about this as
a terrific paper i would commend to your
attention by mason clark uh the russian
russia team lead at the institute for
the study of war
on um russian hybrid warfare uh and
particularly lessons from syria
um where they used this approach
and then wrote about it and so we have
um writings from
actually the guys who are commanding the
war against ukraine right now
the
commander of the southern military
district uh general dwarnikoff was a
commander in syria and wrote
articulately about what he did there the
commander of the western military
district juraj is another syria uh alum
and wrote about his experiences there so
they're quite overt about this stuff the
only trick is a lot of the time
they describe hybrid warfare as as they
claim we do it to them
and they describe
their activities as defensive against
our own hybrid warfare
and
that we initiated this hybrid war and
they are defending against it
and then in that way they describe
exactly what they have been doing and so
you can see them talking about what they
think it is and then you can see
specific actions they take
you can see
russian bot farms that we know
work to manipulate our social media and
that has been revealed talk about that
in some detail so what bot farm what is
that exactly how widespread is it what
is it doing and where
so this this is where you take uh you
you program uh you take you know
computer programs that masquerade as
twitter accounts for example
and they
do lots of different things um sometimes
they will just
uh
either tweet out or uh otherwise message
out uh sort of spam and such volume as
to drown out uh other voices but a lot
of the time what they do is they will
re repeat
uh russian messages
from lots of different accounts that
appear to be independent accounts so
they seem to be corroboration of the
russian narrative but they're actually
all computer programs that are not
they're not even humans and they're all
they're controlled by russia
it's a mimicking of a bottom-up process
right i i'm not the expert on this lots
of people uh
on both sides of the political eye have
written about this there's a lot of
technical detail about this and you you
can find a lot of this is not
questionable this is that this is going
on is not in question any idea how
extensive it is like if if you're on
twitter do you have any sense of what
proportion of responses that you might
be subject to would be i don't know one
of the things that's happened is we got
wise to this after that especially after
the 2016 election when we
uh the u.s became and and i don't want
to get into hold that whole election
controversy there are there are aspects
of what was going on that are not in
question including that there were
russian bot farms
uh sending messages and that they were
exposed and the the cyber details are
clear of what they were
and so on
um as we became aware of that activity
we the u.s
the social media companies like twitter
and others started to get very
aggressive about developing algorithms
to detect when something was a bot and
shut them down
so i believe that we're probably
subjected to a lot less of this than we
were a few years ago
um because and again i don't want to get
any issues of social media blocking
individual humans because that's not
what we're talking about here we're
talking about these are machines
and it is possible to detect that
something is a machine and not a human
and then to shut it down
and that's one of the things that's been
going on so so the social media
companies have been doing good work
in trying to reduce the number of these
things and fight them so i think you're
probably subjected to less of it now
uh than you were in a few years ago but
there's it's still it's still out there
it's still going on okay so let's tie
the hybrid warfare back in so what's the
goal of the hybrid warfare as far as
you're concerned so the goal of the
hybrid warf warfare has been to try to
achieve
putin's objectives without having to do
what he's doing in ukraine right now
because
hybrid warfare is in part a poor man's
game so the we talked about the economic
devastation that uh russia faced in the
90s putin inherited that
um putin has never fixed the russian
economy the russian economy is still
deeply and fundamentally dysfunctional
oscillations and energy prices have
helped him various other things that
he's done have helped him gain
enough money to be able to rebuild his
military to some extent
but his military until very recently
was simply not capable of posing a
serious conventional threat to nato
or hoping plausibly to defend against
nato if it if the russians began a war
and nato seriously leaned into it so
the hybrid warfare approach was designed
to help him achieve
victories in reconstituting soviet power
one way or another without having to
fight wars
and it
worked
pretty well in some important ways but
it reached limits
um so how did it when what ways did it
work do you think so
what the classic example of hybrid
warfare if you like was the little
remember the little green men who turned
up in crimea
in 19 2014
um
and the claims that the russian the
russians were not they were not russian
soldiers they were they were you know
local crimeans who were fed up with
ukrainian
alleged ukrainian oppression and so
forth
um it became rapidly apparent that they
were in fact russian special forces
troops
um
and that the russians did in fact have
troops in ukraine
but even that thinnest veneer of
implausible deniability led to the
following consequence
it led to the establishment by germany
and france with russia and ukraine of
the minsk accords
that that established the air quotes uh
ceasefire in ukraine that held
uh ostensibly from 2015 until putin just
broke it by invading
and here's a fascinating thing about the
minsk accords russia is a party to the
minsk accords as a mediator what
russia is a party to or is a party to
the minsk accords as a mediator
nowhere in the minsk accords is there a
recognition of the fact that it's
russian forces
in ukraine
that the proxy republics that putin just
recognized their independence are
russian controlled
that the chain of command of the forces
of those proxies ran
to the eighth combined arms army which
is russia's headquarters in rastafandam
nowhere in the minsk accords is that
recognized
and so do you think that was made
plausible rendered plausible or possible
even by a successful disinformation
propaganda campaign yep because the
because the russian approach
again and all of this just changed
so i mean there's a whole other
inflection that we need to talk about
about the change that's just occurred
but
the russian approach before this
invasion had been to use disinformation
misinformation and sometimes telling the
truth in weird ways
to generate the following effect who
really knows
that's been the standard that has been
sufficient for putin a high percentage
of the time and unfortunately the rising
skepticism and mistrust within our own
society
has been made that pushing a rock
downhill
we so mistrust each other at this point
that we're inclined to say well who
really knows and so when the russians
are creating
these opportunities to say well who
really knows
the point of that is so that we'll say
well who really knows so why should we
get involved in this
so that instead of reacting to the
russian invasion of ukraine in 2014
which is what actually happened the
russian military invaded ukraine in 2014
it seized and then annexed ukrainian
territory in 2014
and then it continued a war in ukraine
from 2014 to the present the russian
military was doing all of that instead
of that we've been talking about
ceasefire i have a sour joke for you
jordan i've used this joke right up
until the invasion
what do you call it when the armored
mechanized artillery missile aircraft
naval and special forces troops of two
countries fight each other
in ukraine we call it a ceasefire
because that's what happens so by sowing
chaos and confusion at the level of
information you sap the moral unity of
the people that you're attacking so they
can't unite to to justify to themselves
even um a singular and effective
response you what you do is you isolate
the victim which is what the russians
have done
or had done they were isis they isolated
ukraine
so that instead of seeing ukraine simply
as the victim of western of a russian
invasion in 2014 which is what happened
in the west we've had a lot of
conversations about well the are the
ukrainians living up to their
obligations under mints well are they
ukrainians doing enough here and there
you get in rapidly into this you know
well faults on both sides kind of thing
which paralyzes western response there
aren't faults on both sides faults on
one side here
there are faults on the side of the of
of the russians who invaded in 2014 and
have invaded again that's just
themselves that's the consequence of an
injudicious even-handedness exactly
that's a tough one because there's a
strong moral impulse to even-handedness
and also to self-correction right to
examine yourself for your own faults
which we seem to be more than good
enough in some sense in the west yeah
but that can be capitalized on and it's
an interesting moral conundrum isn't it
because there's a time for decisive
action that requires a certain level of
moral certainty and that means you're
not even you're not even handed under
those conditions
so
so okay so so now let me ask you another
question that's associated perhaps on
with the disinformation front there are
many people
around the world in the west as well
claiming that in some real sense ukraine
isn't an independent state it's part of
russia it has been historically it's not
germany it's not a country with a clear
like historical existence it's a
and so so so what what what do you so
you're obviously not very happy with
that argument but that is being made
continually and so i know i know i'm
laughing because you you mentioned
germany
and the the natural you know of that of
course germany is naturally a country
really that right right that wasn't the
that wasn't a a natural thought until
1871
right right right well we forget about
all
how difficult was for those countries we
think were all who are forever around to
unify themselves exactly yeah so and
look so and and you know there was
historically a lot of argument about
exactly what germany was
and then of course hitler had i mean
like world war ii right and then of
course hitler had a view of what germany
included and it included things like
austria and czechoslovakia
um and you know we we uh
persuaded the germans that that was not
the case after some considerable effort
um the analogy is apt
because you can look at austrians and
say well they're germans
well
they speak german
they're catholics
the dominant religion in germany is
protestantism
austrians are largely catholic
you can tell when you get into austria
and southern germany by the way when the
when the greeting changes from guten tag
to gruscott
rich there's also no shortage of
dialectical variation across the
hypothetically unified german language
exactly like extreme dialectical
variation exactly right so we we've got
to not just imagine that the blocks that
we're used to in europe are were always
that way or have been for centuries
because that's not true either
how do we reliably identify when there
is a country well okay let me come back
to that because there's a
straightforward answer to that
but
the it was the kenyan um
president or prime minister um
whom i can't believe i'm quoting
approvingly because i i rarely approve
of anything that he has to say um but
who put this very well uh recently in a
very very strong statement
um
that look
if we want to get into the business of
talking about how
it should be the case
that all peoples who identify ethnically
with other people should be unified in
country in single states
then you were signing the world up for
global war
on a on a hobsian scale of a sort that
we have never seen because
look at look at africa look at asia
look well
i'll leave that to you jordan but how
many countries in the world actually are
drawn that way
virtually right so okay so the
fundamental point here is is that
mere linguistic uh historical similarity
is not a sufficient condition for
presuming a superordinate autonomy
exactly and so we have other mechanisms
to decide what a country is and they're
very straightforward mechanisms we live
in a world where there's a there is a
united nations and there is a body of
states
and the community of states
recognizes a new member
by recognizing it
and we say we recognize you as an
independent state and we establish
diplomatic relations with them and we
give them a seat in the united nations
and then
they are a state with all of the rights
that any other state has
we did that with all of the states of
the former soviet union
and russia signed up to all of that
when did that happen in 1990 ukraine in
1991 1992
all of the states all of the former
soviet states including russia
were recognized as independent states
establish diplomatic relations with the
world that's the only standard there is
okay so that goes back to your initial
claim that what putin is doing was
you said unprovoked unwarranted and
illegal so now we've established the
illegality element of that it's like he
had signed agreements or russia had
signed agreements stating that as far as
they were concerned ukraine was a
country among other countries and more
than that
they did something even more
because when the soviet union fell
parts of its nuclear arsenal
were still in three other countries in
belarus ukraine and kazakhstan
and we worked very hard
to persuade those countries we the
united states and great britain worked
very hard to persuade those countries to
give their nuclear arsenals back to
russia
because we were very concerned about the
threat of nuclear proliferation
so we presented and they did
in return for that in 1994 we britain
and russia signed an agreement with
ukraine
committing to respect the territorial
integrity of ukraine as it was
recognized at the time
in return for ukraine handing back those
uh nuclear weapons
the russians signed that treaty the
russians have just violated a treaty
that they specifically signed with
ukraine recognizing
it in its territorial integrity as it
was in 1994 who who signed that on
russia's behalf yeltsin that was yeltsin
okay so putin hypothetically doesn't
feel that he's bound by that agreement
but within the framework of
international law he is he is i mean he
can regard himself however he wants to
but he is
so not only did russia recognize ukraine
as a country but it specifically
recognized ukraine in the borders that
it had in 1994.
okay so
all right so so
let's go to
unprovoked now here's a mystery
this could have happened at any time
over the last
20 years or anytime into the future over
the next 20 years but it happened
now and there are accusations of all
sorts flying around on the political
front in the west about why now
as far as you're concerned
why now and
and
is there a lesson in
the fact that it's now for us so let me
uh i'll go into this little deeper i
read a couple of papers by victor davis
hanson
yesterday and he made a claim that was
approximately the following which is
that
um
the the democrats for example under
obama
talked about russia in a negative way
but really didn't do anything about
russia whereas trump
gave
putin flattery in some sense but
actually did something about
the potential danger they posed and i'm
not claiming that that's a valid
argument or an invalid argument it's
just something that i read when i was
trying to prepare for this
why now because it is being politicized
like mad in in the west we think well
putin is taking advantage of our
perceived weakness and there's
partisan reasons for that and maybe
there's deeper philosophical reasons for
that those need to be separated as far
as you're concerned why now and then we
do need to get to also maybe why we
how we stepped into this even if it was
only 20 or a fault or two percent i
don't care what did we do wrong that
made this happen and happen now
so look the the question
the answer to the question why now is
very is very hard i think and i this is
something that i'm also wrestling with
because the what do we what we need to
explain is the invasion
that putin has been carrying forward
operations to regain control of ukraine
since 2014.
he has been pursuing hybrid warfare
approaches pursuing informational
operation approaches in ukraine he's put
various forms of military pressure on
ukraine from his occupied territories uh
right so it's not exactly now this is
actually an extension of a process
that's been occurring for a long time
it's an inflection in that process now
so what we need to explain this
particular inflection which is a huge
inflection
um but that's actually rather hard to be
honest with you
um
and it's
there's no simple partisan or
straightforward explanation uh to why
putin decided that he needed to invade
now which is the question that is that
preoccupies me as someone who's focused
on putin's calculus well the best
explanation i've heard so far and it
goes along with this gradualist idea in
some sense is that part of what putin
did while he was attempting to rest back
control of ukraine let's say is build a
military presence on the border yeah and
then the fact that you've done that
actually changes the situation
substantially if you're going to build
if you're much more likely to shoot
someone with a gun if you happen to be
pointing holding it and pointing it at
them
as a precursor and so you could see how
a gradualist approach and his initial
idea might have just been well we'll
build up the military to put even more
pressure on the west and to continue
this gradualist approach but once it's
there the situation changes and then it
could be in some sense relatively small
and relatively random events that
precipitate it at any given moment
so
i think it's quite possible that
something like that occurred
um
there's a lot of technical details about
so i i want to say on the air to you
what i've been saying to other people
that i talked to i got this wrong
okay we we made a forecast i and the isw
russia team made a forecast
um beginning in uh november and then
carrying forward until very recently
that putin would not launch this huge
invasion
and we we were wrong obviously he did
um and and i you know as a matter of
analytical integrity i feel it necessary
to say to people explicitly yes we were
wrong in our forecast
and we've been spent a lot of time
trying to understand and think about why
we were wrong and what lessons we can
learn from that
um here's one of the reasons why we were
wrong
or let me say this is one of the reasons
why we forecast that he would not do
this because when you look actually at
the technical details of the way that he
arrayed his forces around ukraine
we were watching that and saying
this is going to stink this military
operation that he's conducting he's not
well set up to do this
surely his professional military
officers are going to tell him that this
is a bad idea
and it turns out that we were wrong that
he would be persuaded by that reality
but we were right that it was a bad idea
because the problems that he's now
encountering we actually did predict
that he would have the problems that
he's now encountering if he conducted
this opposition
okay so it isn't obvious what
precipitated this and there isn't an
obvious moral to derive from the story
but yeah there are errors in it and and
okay
we'll get to errors but i you know
before we get to our own errors because
you know i've got to tell you this one
of my one of the things that i'm very
focused on is you need to start by
blaming the enemy for things the enemy
does i'm happy to talk about what our
responsibilities are here but this was
all putin's decision
and i'd i'm actually more interested in
in in some sense now what our
responsibilities are going forward okay
right so so because that's the crucial
issue but and i'd like to hear i when i
commented about mistakes then i was
thinking you said his troops were badly
positioned his military machine was
badly positioned and so that might mean
he was setting it up for other reasons
but defaulted to this
why did that what is the situation he's
in now because well he's not finding
allies at that rapid rate
let's say no no he's not finding really
allies at all look the first thing i
want to say is i think it's quite
possible that he decided to launch this
invasion because
the intent of the mobilization i think
is possible the intent of the
mobilization was to intimidate both the
ukrainians and the west into
surrendering
without having to invade and that he he
therefore you know allowed his military
guys
to set up a deployment that didn't make
sense for an invasion but was great for
threatening
one of the things that happened at the
byte administration deserves a lot of
credit for at least one thing that it's
done actually for a few things that it's
done deserves some criticism for other
things but
for the first time in history that i'm
aware of the biden administration
fought a counter-hybrid warfare campaign
back against the russians
and as they became as the bite
administration became aware of russian
preparations to conduct a coup d'etat in
kiev
they told the ukrainians about it and
they told the world about it as they
became aware of multiple russian
preparations to conduct false flag
attacks or stage ukrainian provocations
or various other things that would have
given putin informational cover
and created a who really knows effect
in the minds of people in the west they
blew the biden administration blew every
one of those operations okay so why is
that a hybrid warfare response on on
biden's part and not just
not just i don't mean just but not just
the utility of straightforwardness and
honesty as a response to disinformation
and propaganda it's both or is that is
it's okay
it's both
we can wage war with the truth because
we're not trying to lie
putin is trying to create a false
universe putin is trying to create a
fictitious universe and the bible
administration punctured that i'm
calling it hybrid warfare because they
reacted to first of all putin engaged in
violence and which makes it you know
politically motivated violence which
makes it warfare
and he his guys were conducting
deliberate information campaigns to
support specific preparations for
military activities
and the biden administration engaged
game for game with them on a very
tactical level so it wasn't just sort of
blanket telling the truth it was
finding strategic
as well strategic and tactical blowing
all and informed yeah
and you can by the way see i have a
little artifact artifact that suggests
that this was true because putin held
one of his weirdly publicly staged you
know national security council meetings
on uh monday
and one of the things that happened was
he absolutely humiliated
the guy who is the head of his foreign
intelligence agency that would have been
responsible for a lot of these
operations i mean he humiliated the guy
in public in a way that we've never seen
him do before
and i think he probably was genuinely
angry that the guy had allowed the biden
administration to get inside all of
these operations and i am hypothesizing
that putin decided
in the face of having all of this cover
blown
decided that he was just going to go for
it instead of waiting for
this guy nadeshkin or somebody else to
get something putin just said okay screw
it we've got the forces i'm tired of
this we're just going to do this and i
don't care that we don't have the
informational cover
so frustration and anger
in response possibly to the success of
the bible administration sort of
defeating all the informational stuff
okay okay well that's that's an
interesting uh explanation for a tipping
point and certainly not an expected one
so
so you've covered unprovoked unwarranted
and illegal i would say and we've
covered territorial ambitions or
political ambitions and we've talked a
lot about reconstituting the soviet
empire let's say or something
approximating that
um
do you think it's we're
so so let's switch to something else
is what he's
uh how do you assess the success of what
he's doing from a military and a
political perspective has he
miscalculated
uh what what's the situation on the
ground in the ukraine how are the
ukrainians resisting uh
how are how are other countries
responding like what's the situation in
your estimation
so i i'm going to lead by saying
uh the russia you know the russian
military is so much stronger than the
ukrainian military writ large that
the odds remain high that the russian
military will be able ultimately to
overwhelm the ukrainian defenses
and take control of kiev and so forth i
don't want to offer an optimistic take
here because we're still early days in
this war and the power imbalance is just
so great
but
that having been said
i would never have expected to be
sitting here four days into the russian
military operation with russian troops
just messing around on the outskirts of
kiev just finally getting into harkief
and struggling all up and down them i
would never have expected that to happen
except
that we we did
expect it to be a mess
when they tried to do an invasion with
the force packages that they had put
together
especially those that are attacking kiev
and uh and harkeef
so
a few things have gone on one is this
was a stupid way of of preparing for an
invasion if you were serious about an
invasion i'll give you what wait yeah
give some details i think that'd be
interesting so here's the thing um
mechanized maneuver warfare is very
complicated undertaking
logistically well yes logistically but
even more than that in terms of command
and control
um when you are a commander
and you've got multiple battalions
mechanized battalions moving down
multiple axes of advance
sort of driving down different roads to
different targets
rapidly
keeping track of all of that is very
hard understanding what they're doing is
very hard figuring out how to support
them is very hard they need artillery
support they need air support they do
need logistics support you need to tell
them what to do as they get to
particular or as they run into problems
it's a lot of burden on a commander to
keep track of a lot of subordinates
so the solution for
as long as there's been mechanized
warfare is that you build forces where
you never have more than two or three or
maximum four
direct subordinate units like that so
battalions get grouped into regiments or
brigades which are at the same echelon
uh in an organizational structure and
there will be not more than than four
uh maneuvering battalions or mechanized
battalions within a mechanized regiment
or a mechanized brigade and then
brigades and regiments get grouped into
divisions so there's not going to be
more than three or four brigades or
regiments in a division and then the
divisions are grouped into larger uh
organizations and this is the way the
u.s military is organized and it's the
way the russian military is organized
formally but the weird thing is that
when they put these masses of forces
into belarus and into western russia
that are now attacking kiev and when
they built up forces opposite kharkiv
they didn't move entire regiments or
brigades let alone entire divisions they
pulled individual battalion what they
call battalion tactical groups btgs they
pulled individual btgs from all across
russia
the guys in belarus actually came from
out of 10 or 15 different regiments and
brigades in the russian far east
and did they do that to not weaken those
divisions and brigades where they were
already located no no because they're
most of this all the stuff in belarus is
coming in a place where the russians
don't need to worry about their chinese
are not invading the russian far east so
the russians could have taken whole
regiments or brigades from the far east
if they'd wanted to and they didn't that
they're various i can offer various
technical explanations for why they
might not have
but the point is that they they put
together what we we're we're calling
just sort of collection of cats and dogs
of battalions
one together from a whole bunch of other
parent units
not organized coherently
even on the spot as far as we can tell
into
clear regiment brigade structures and
all like that and then they just sort of
told them go down you know drive down
the road and go take keith
okay that gets you the kind of mess that
they have now
where they try to they you know
individual battalion groups drive down
and then they get stopped but then
there's not a good coordination so that
there's not an immediate other battalion
that can take over and flank and keep
the attack moving there are all kinds of
ways of dealing with the defenses the
ukrainians are putting up and the
russians are not using them
and i i think that that has a lot to do
with the organization of the russian
forces that is just it was just crazy as
an organization for a mechanized
operation like this
and then putin assumed that just brute
force numbers in some sense would
overcome that possibly this that
disarray in organizational structure
possibly but it but i think another
answer goes to your second question
the ukrainians are fighting like lions
they they are they are fighting like
heroes
it's it's unbelievable the determination
with which i thought they would fight i
mean i know ukrainians and i i thought
that they would fight
um
they are fighting with a hard and
effectively
i'm certain that putin did not expect
them to okay so he's having a lot more
trouble locally than
he might have expected for a multitude
of reasons poor organization to begin
with which which seems in keeping with
the notion that the troops were put
there as an intimidation rather than as
a reliable military force for an
invasion yep sure sure all this is
provisional and also the ukrainians are
entrenching and fighting back with a
ferocity that was unexpected
yeah they have more to to lose in some
sense than the russians have to gain so
that's always dangerous that's a
dangerous
inequality in
um morality in warfare and that's not to
be underestimated and so what's
happening
on the international front in response
to the cohesiveness of the response to
the invasion
this has been very um heartening and it
goes to
[Music]
the other one of the other reasons why i
thought putin wouldn't do this because
the international community is rallying
um and we i we can have frustrations
with the way individual states are
responding to specific requests and so
forth and i have been frustrated by that
um as everybody else has been but the
truth is in
if you get out of the time dilated world
we're in in which if something doesn't
happen five seconds from now then it's
taking a long time we're talking about
within three to four days
we've got the russians being partially
kicked out of swift we've got sanctions
on the russian central bank we've got
the germans for the first time since the
second world war directly sending lethal
aid to the ukrainians
we've got virtual unanimity in
condemning the russian attack
are there any exceptions
and i want to go back to swift as well
okay yes there are exceptions bashar
al-assad continues to demonstrate
what an evil slime ball he actually is
and how much he owes the russians
because he immediately recognized the
russian recognition of donbass
of the nyskan luhansk and for those that
don't know he is the dictator of syria
who has been conducting his own little
genocide there with russian as active
assistance
right so he's just the kind of ally
you'd hope the russians would have
exactly
uh i haven't tracked this i think the
venezuelans have made good noises again
um when you know maduro's on your side
you ought to be thinking hard about
your life choices
um
and the the iranian um what they call
the axis of resistance i think was very
prompt in recognizing the uh the
recognition of republics and iranians
are generally focused on blaming nato
for the russian invasion of ukraine
um but other than that even xi jinping
could not bring himself to veto the u.n
security council resolution condemning
the invasion he just abstained
and
we can right so that's a big deal it's a
big deal it tells you that what putin
has done is even she is going you know
volva i'm not sure that i can actually
support you on this the way you've done
this there's just no cover he's putin
has given himself no cover
and so hungary
even the hungarian supported uh kicking
him out of swift
and so let's go into the swift issue to
some degree because people won't know
what that is and why it's important it's
very complicated and it is in some
respects overblown
um swift is a a european consortium
that is the means by which banks
communicate with one another to do bank
to bank transfers
and if you are kicked out of swift
then
you have to find other ways
of communicating with banks
in order to do bank to bank transfers
there are other ways
but it's harder it's much harder it's
much more it's much slower it's more pr
it's it it is a he introduces all kinds
of friction
into bank to bank transactions which is
important because the russians rely on
dollar reserves
uh for
their reserves and having when they have
challenges interacting with the dollar
market globally it's a big problem for
them and getting them
interfering with their ability to use
swift uh
makes that much harder for them sure it
makes it harder for them to do what so
they can make it harder
to move money around including to regain
you know reclaim money that is abroad or
to move money to buy things or various
other things that states do and that
individuals try to do using banks and so
on it just throws a huge amount of sand
in the gears of all of that
do the russians use swift to move money
between the banks in russia or is that
all international uh i don't know how
they do it in within within russia i'm
sure they can work that out internally
but the
getting getting abroad is a whole other
is a whole other story
okay but important as swift is actually
the sanctions on the russian central
bank are even more important
because swift is just a means of
communication and it is important and
i'm glad that we've you know gotten
gotten people around on that for the
most part but we've been we're you know
we've got uh the eu imposing sanctions
on the central bank
um that's a big deal that's a very big
deal because what does that mean
it can make it hard to impossible for
the russian central bank actually to
play on the dollar market and to use
engage in the dollar economy which is a
problem because the global economy
remains fundamentally a dollar economy
and as the ruble is predictably
collapsing
as this is going on
the russia in fact there's a joke going
around russians
russians from the soviet days and even
before have have a very dark sense of
humor and they excel at that as i'm sure
you know but one joke going around as
soon as the invasion began was
um uh could you kindly tell us that
before you invade somebody else the next
time so we can buy dollars
right um so russians need dollars and
uh sanctioning the central bank makes it
hard to impossible for the russian
government
to deal in dollars and to interact in
that way
and how how long how long will it take
the consequences of that to unfold um in
in some way that actually bites
particularly on the military front
well i mean so okay the problem is i
don't know that it will bite on the
military front um
because we need to keep something in
mind that a lesson that we learned from
the soviet union a dictatorship can
generally do any one thing that it
decides to do
when you're running a country the
resources that are available to you
sanctions notwithstanding you can
usually choose any one thing and
actually make that happen
so the soviet military threat for
example reached its height
at the same time as the soviet economy
began to go into terminal decline in the
1980s
those two facts were probably related to
one another with some causality by the
way
putin has a similar phenomenon here i
think he probably can keep his military
going but what's going to happen is the
russian economy
will collapse i don't know exactly what
that means but will be badly harmed
um
at some point okay you know what do you
think now do you think that so okay so
you you can imagine two consequences of
that one would be that support for putin
within the country vanishes and the
demonstrations that we've already seen
start to increase in scope and i suppose
the other possibility is
you know bombing people into submission
so to speak often produces much more
resistance than anyone attempts or it
intends or assumes and so
is there any possibility that these
sanctions might backfire and increase
support for putin or do you think that
disintegration into chaos uh
possibilities is more probable
the sanctions are so the the last thing
that i want to flag for you which is
part of our own self reflection on why
we got it wrong is we assumed that putin
would prepare his people for a big war
we assumed that before he attacked he
would have spent days if not weeks
telling his people basically that he was
going to have to fight a big war and
here's why and that they were going to
suffer but it was going to be necessary
and good for them and he did the exact
opposite as he was getting ready to
invade
the russian officials were lampooning
the west as we kept saying that he's
about to invade they were talking to the
russian people and laughing at us and
saying look at these stupid westerners
who think we're going to invade that's
ridiculous
he did nothing to prepare his people for
this war and that's been evident and the
protests that you're seeing
and the word that is coming out even
from the sectors
near kharkiv from near the border near
kharkiv where the russians concentrated
all of these forces i've seen western
interviews
uh we're talking to russians near the
border who say we had no idea we were
shocked when this thing kicked off
so he's done nothing to prepare his
people for the war which is why have you
ever seen anything like these
demonstrations okay so let's we could
talk about that a little bit because
it's not like we're accustomed to seeing
demonstrations in russia not on the
scene that's not a thing
so
so so
how do you you account for that at least
in part by the fact that this is a
terrible shock to people and that they
can see that it's going to cost them
they feel betrayed by this but also
it's no trivial thing to demonstrate in
a place like russia being
that's right you put you put yourself at
some risk here but not very much by
doing that but there it's it's he's
reportedly already arrested 1600 people
for demonstrating and those people are
certainly having a very hard time in
prison
um and will probably never emerge again
i would predict and he's i think he's
going to have to get in the business of
killing a lot of russians
um if this protracts they're not going
to blame us
we are not going to be the target of the
anger for the sanctions and the economic
suffering at this point
but it's it's not just the sanctions and
i want to be clear about this this and
this is the other part of why i thought
he'd have to prepare his people
lots of polls show that russians see
america as an enemy and a threat and all
of that kind of stuff he spent 20 years
getting russians uh to believe that and
of course there's the soviet hangover of
a lot of comfort in russia
you know believing that
russians have not seen ukraine as an
enemy
and all of the language that he's been
using about these are our fraternal
slavic brothers and they we need to
bring them back to the fold and all of
that kind of stuff
that's been the messaging
and he's been talking about you know we
need to remove this illegal junta that's
in kiev he's got a whole narrative about
how this really is in a war against the
ukrainian people right now that's stupid
now it is they're blowing up apartment
blocks and stuff now he's trying to keep
that from his people
but again russians are not that stupid
and they are they are understanding that
this is a war against ukraine and that a
lot of russians i think are just
why are we fighting ukraine why are we
attacking ukraine you tell me the
americans are the enemy so in so far in
so far as they are they're slavic
brothers this is now tantamount to a
civil war right
right right if that narrative was
originally true right right
so it's he's just he's totally failed to
prepare anybody informationally for this
and that is one of the things that is
generating this this outrage in russia
over this unprovoked war of aggression
against a
a brother slavic state
that did not attack russia and wasn't
threatening russia and where there are
no americans
because again you mean you could tell
the russian people that the americans
are the threat but there are no
americans in ukraine we're not fighting
americans in ukraine
so
he has a problem
and i think it's going to many many
problems
so okay so let's we're we're let's move
to
future actions yeah so the the west is
united well the world is united except
for the exceptions that you already
described and putin is having a lot of
trouble on the ground and as far as
you're concerned he wasn't well prepared
either on the propaganda or the military
front and he's going to suffer
substantial economic costs and so this
at the moment this does not look like
it's going well for him okay so we could
be happy about that except that there
are also nuclear weapons and that's
always something to think about what
what
how do we not what's the right reaction
it's not an under reaction it's not an
overreaction what do you think is an
intelligent pathway forward as far as
you're concerned and are you do you feel
comfortable in even detailing out such a
thing sure
yeah i'm comfortable with it there's you
know we don't we don't do secrets very
well and that's um you know this is this
is straightforward
um so
i guess i'm not confident in your
knowledge about making such a such a
such a suggestion
as you can see i'm comfortable making
forecasts and recommendations with the
possibility that they'll be wrong
and i'll accept the consequence if they
are that's it's my job to do that
um
so
right now we're doing the most important
thing that we should be doing which is
rushing the most important kinds of
defensive weapons to ukraine uh as much
as we can um we need to try to help the
ukrainians save their country if there's
any way for them to do that um and we
need to believe the russian military
badly
um if we can't i am very confident that
there will be
a ukrainian insurgency if putin
overcomes the ukrainian conventional
forces and this can turn into ukraine uh
putin's afghanistan war
um and we should absolutely help the
ukrainians win that as quickly as
possible
um and that that will be world changing
we we need to do that
um and what sort of defensive weapons
we're sending so we're sending primarily
what they need are anti-tank uh
weapons which are mainly javelin
anti-tank uh man portable you can fire
them from your shoulder
missiles
um and stinger um anti-aircraft missiles
again you know we we sent stingers to
the mujahideen in afghanistan in the
1980s um and it did fear for harm to the
to the soviets and we're standing
stingers here too and the ukrainians are
using them to could affect against
russian aircraft today
those are the most important things we
need to do i'm sure that there's also
sort of basic ammunition and stuff that
we
need to send also humanitarian supplies
and they're
increasing other organizations
i don't have the list right now but
they're organizations getting together
to send humanitarian relief to to
ukraine i encourage everybody to do that
um as long as there is any an
independent ukraine it's going to need a
lot of help because the russians are
doing fearful damage to it and we'll do
more
so that's what people people can do that
at a local level yeah and maybe we can
put some links in the description of
this video i'd like links from you
for recommended papers okay so that
people can familiarize themselves but
also anything you could provide us that
would would help in that practical sense
would be useful as well okay you bet uh
yep right start with our websites
understandingwar.org and
criticalthreats.org
um and we we have daily and and
sometimes several times a day updates of
exactly what's going on
uh with maps and a lot of detail um
so
um
and and i'll i'll i'll try to find you
some links for organizations that are
that are doing good work here um i'll
name one spirit of america uh has has
historically done really great work and
they've got a ukraine program going
um so we're doing all of that stuff and
that's great um we're gonna bring a lot
of economic pain on putin and that's
great
um
look
a wounded bear is a very dangerous
animal
and we must not be complacent about this
i want to bound what i'm worried about
here from for your listeners okay
we're not going to get into a global
thermonuclear exchange that ends the
world
why not because
as crazy as putin might or might not be
he's not that crazy
why do you believe that because the
because
we are not going to do anything that is
going to put the survival of russia at
stake
in such a clear okay so that's part of
the issue of a measured response is that
so the measured response is to to insist
upon the territorial integrity of the of
ukraine right and that's it i mean we're
not going to absolutely we're not going
to attack russia we're not going to we
never were going to attack russia we're
not going to attack russia
and we're certainly not going to invade
i mean you know we know anything from
history do you do you want to invade
drive from warsaw to moscow again uh no
one who's ever tried that has enjoyed it
so we were never going to do that and
we're never going to do that we're not
going to put the survival of the russian
of russia at stake putin is not going to
uh end the world
um because we're never going to back him
into a corner uh like that that hard
yeah
now i am worried about an a conventional
expansion of this conflict
yeah well because i was wondering when
you were saying we start to fun funnel
in defense of weapons well at what point
well not we should be the global
community not the united states to the
degree that that's possible
and then but it's still at what point
does the funneling of defensive weapons
become active engagement in the war
process i mean that means the movement
of troops i would presume from other
countries that maybe that's a dividing
no i mean no one is sending no other
countries are sending troops into
ukraine
and you and you think that's that's
appropriate certainly at the time and
perhaps into the future
that i'm going to tell you the the
i'm going to tell you what i'm worried
about before i say that that that's
appropriate indefinitely
look um
we know what putin did to syria
we know in syria that russian russia was
using precision guided munitions to
attack bread lines and hospitals in
syria
we know that he was supporting what the
war called siege and starve campaigns
to compel communities to surrender by
literally cutting them off from food and
water
and watching them die until they
surrendered these are things that russia
did in syria and it's very well
documented
in fact i mean like the doctors without
borders and other organizations had to
stop announcing the locations of their
medical facilities in syria because the
russians were using those lists which
are supposed to be do not strike lists
as target lists
they did that in syria
if they start doing that in ukraine
and i'm very worried about the fact that
the russians are bringing weapons toward
heart cave
of the sort that one uses to exterminate
city blocks
in short order
i'm hoping that that's not what they're
going to do with those weapons if they
do anything with them
the west is going to ask have to ask
itself
if the russians go that route in ukraine
are we actually just going to stand by
and watch
i don't have i'm not going to offer you
an answer i'm just telling you that
that's a decision to take down
if they go there and i hope that they
don't
um but
to be as long as they don't go there i'm
we're not going to see western troops
going into ukraine and i'm not going to
advocate for that and i'm not i'm not
getting into you know i'm not suggesting
that we should do that
um now we should do everything we can to
help the ukrainians defend themselves
putin has said that it is an act of
aggression to help the ukrainians defend
themselves which is not true
but he has asserted that and he has
threatened to attack the countries that
are helping the ukrainians might he
attack poland yes he might
he might attack poland i can absolutely
see russian missile strikes or
airstrikes into poland or into hungary
or into romania
or into any of the states that are which
would be an attack on nato territory
which would activate article 5 of the
nato treaty
which would mean what would have to
happen well
it would mean that that we and all of
the other nato member states would need
to vote to activate article 5 which i
would hope that we would do
um and then what we would do what i
would like to see us do is what we are
now doing which is or an acceleration of
what we are now doing which is sending
american military power and also british
and french and other countries military
power to
the nato borders
to the eastern nato borders in a
defensive posture
to defend
there's no no one is talking about
attacking
but we have to be prepared to defend
against these sorts of things the
complexity will come
if the russians actually begin rocketing
or firing missiles into poland
the defense against that is counter
battery fire and at a certain point you
do start to have to shoot that shoot
back
at russia and the defense the line
between defense and offense is quite
blurry well
it's not in a legal sense this is you
know legally that would not be an
offensive action the russians would have
engaged in an act of war against poland
and poland and nato would poland would
then have a right under international
law to defend itself and nato would have
a right under article 5 and collective
security agreements to come to poland's
defense in that regard
no one is going to talk about a ground
invasion of belarus or russia or
kaliningrad or anything i am confident
that nato will act if it acts militarily
at all in an entirely defensive fashion
and for the simply for the purpose of
eliminating
known imminent threats of attack to
member states
but no one is going to talk about an
invasion and we're not going to do that
but we are going to have to
change our force posture very
fundamentally
which is going to have all kinds of
ripple effects
because this this is not a short-term
crisis
this the threat that putin is
manifesting is a threat that's going to
be here as long as putin is here
so we're going to have to be prepared to
defend
poland and romania and the baltic states
from
russian the russian conventional threat
for the first time since the end of the
cold war
we're going to have to be prepared
to defend against the risk of a russian
mechanized attack
on nato member states the u.s defense
budget is not built to do that the u.s
force posture is not structured to do
that our national security documents are
not built to do that we're going to have
to change all of that
and we're going to have to rebuild some
defense capability and we're going to
have to spend more on defense because
china hasn't gone away we've spent more
than 90 minutes here talking about
russia we haven't talked about china
which is great because i'm not a china
expert
but this doesn't reduce the threat that
china poses to taiwan or the
requirements to beef up our capabilities
in the pacific by the way we've got
problems in the middle east still going
on we haven't talked about that either
and we've got an ongoing
series of wars in the middle east that
can engage us at any moment we've got to
get serious about our defenses
and i can tell you right now that the
defense budget that we're operating
under is insufficient
by a lot
and no one wants to hear this no one
wants to spend more on defense but
it's the world is at war
so let's let's sum up a bit and then
let's see if there's anything else we
need to cover we've it's been a pretty
comprehensive discussion and
and uh
we've we've talked about an unprovoked
unwarranted and illegal attack by russia
on ukraine which is by all indications a
sovereign state by legally and otherwise
um we've talked about why the russians
might have been motivated to do that
historically and also proximally
uh we've talked about the situation on
the ground and internationally the
russians are having more trouble than
they might have uh predicted on both
fronts and i suppose that's good news in
some sense for the rest of the world and
for ukraine we've talked about the
pitfalls associated with that
we've talked about how this might move
forward
and should move forward partly in terms
of supporting
ukraine's
and the ukrainians attempts to defend
themselves and then what might occur
after that
you've talked about your belief that the
world response because i won't call it
the western response the world response
is likely to be
measured and careful and that as far as
you're concerned at the moment you don't
see radical danger in this
tit for tatting up to some
ultimate exchange
and so
well i'm wondering if there's anything
else you think it's it would be useful
to bring to the attention of people at
this particular point we can always have
a conversation like this again as things
unfold
anything else you think that that is
necessary for people to understand right
now
i think that um
i i just want to end by uh saluting
the heroic ukrainians
who are defending themselves valiantly
against this attack
uh salute all of those who help them
and i will sign off as i will uh going
forward while this war is going on and
while there's a free ukraine slava
ukrainian glory to ukraine
well thanks very much for talking to me
today and we'll get this up as soon as
we possibly can thank you so much thanks
for having me my pleasure my pleasure
[Music]
you